the idea to make a movie inspired by The
Snow Queen the Hans Christian Andersen
fairy tale has been percolating at
Disney for a while well I know that Walt
always wanted to do it we really didn't
see any transcripts or anything I don't
know I don't know if there any left but
I think it was what was it 1939 that we
found out and there was actually a
production number given to the to the
show so and 1092 yes we know these facts
now and but I didn't know during the
making of it and we just saw we were
just with Alice Davis yesterday looking
at some artwork that Mark Davis had done
and it was actually for more of an
attraction at Disneyland ice palace yes
so so it's been kicking around there was
they tried some versions in the early I
think late 90s early 2000s I came back
in 2008 came back to Disney and John
Lasseter asked me to come back and it
was one of the projects that was you
know still there and it just intrigued
me with the environment which I thought
was amazing it's already magical you've
got the ice and snow which is so
beautiful and Disney never done a full
feature in the ice and snow and then the
the character self The Snow Queen who is
so intriguing she's not really very well
defined in the action in the Hans
Christian Andersen's story so but there
were a lot of questions about that and
that's where we we sort of played a
little bit more with that so that sort
of worked started I had been a writer on
wreck-it Ralph and that's how I came to
Disney and so I was very familiar used
to being in the story room and writers
are in the editorial rooms as well and
and they work with the actors - so is it
very comfortable and I love frozen I
what we do at Disney is we sort of help
each other with their move each other's
movies we go in and give notes every few
weeks they put up the film and we'll
look at it and give notes and I was
really falling for frozen and giving
notes and and Peter and Chris could see
I was connecting with
and asked as I was almost done or
through if I would come on and and write
frozen and I was delighted and then John
and Edie kind of watching how we all
work together and watching Chris and I
particularly felt like we made a great
team and you know we have very intense
schedule and they asked if I would code
rec with Chris and in that is rare I'm
the first writer to do that normally
it's an animator who works many many
years up and to become a director but I
think we were just such a good team
story-wise I could keep that going and
he could keep the animation going if
needed and it just it just worked out
for us we're very fortunate Kristen
anderson-lopez great lyricist Award
winner and Bobby Lopez of course won a
Tony Award for Book of Mormon and Avenue
Q and since I had worked with them
previously was very familiar with them
and when Chris said that he wanted this
to be a musical we wanted to embrace
that and the reason I think not only did
Chris enjoy going to New York and seeing
those productions but we knew that it
was really important to have writers on
from the very very beginning of the
project so I joined two and a half years
ago I believe they joined probably about
two years ago and we're in every
everyday we met with them for at least
two hours a lot of times it was via
videoconference because they were in New
York but we talked about character we
talked about story we talked about the
arc of the characters long before they
wrote any songs and that was really
important because we always knew we
wanted the songs to do one of two things
either tell you something about the
character that they that you didn't know
before or to propel the story forward
and to do that they had to be intimately
involved with the story process we
wanted to integrate the characters and
they don't just walk on snow they're
inside of it they're falling in it
they're walking through two feet of snow
and we wanted to create ice that was
powerful and emotional because it's it's
created magically by Elsa and to do that
the technology was not there before at
all we had to build it in the very
beginning the snow would sort of clump
like packing peanuts and they built some
incredible stuff we once called the
Matterhorn which is very Disney there's
a snow batcher and and then they also
with the ice we found
you could do glass or plastic looking
ice very easily but like humans ice is
very flawed and that's what makes it
beautiful and so we had to like hand go
in and create flaws so the ice felt like
ice and we must say we don't go for
realism I think when you go for realism
and animation it can pull you out but we
go for believability and in doing that
it's a feeling you can feel when it's
it's not ice to you and and so the team
pushed harder than they ever had that
technology took many many many hours to
render on the computer it was tough and
we did our research too we did a lot of
research we sent Peter didn't send us
but our but our artists got to go to an
ice hotel first
there's one in Quebec City again we saw
how the light would come in and refract
and reflect off of the ice and and the
the team did some they took some
beautiful videos and pictures and that
really inspired them for Elsa's ice
palace and then they also went to our
animators went to Wyoming to study what
it would be like to actually walk in
with that big skirt that on a walks in
in the snow and the men and the women
animators we only you know they got to
walk through it and that was tough but
we got a lot of great video and they
felt it they really when you're doing
animation it's good if you've actually
experienced something like that and then
you guys have talked about the other
trip the big big trip was to Norway and
and a lot of that you know is
environment and that's a big part but
also the culture it's the balance
technology-wise you know we wanted to
we've got more simulated cloth in this
film than any film all our films
together combined and it was the
discovery of the intimacy of the
Norwegian folk art and the stave
churches and the Rose mulling and
balancing that against the Giants know a
few words which it was the perfect
landscape we could create intimacy and
intimate setting with the characters and
then put them at this adventure that was
giant and scope and and very treacherous
and it was the greatest inspiration I
think for us for the film and at the
beginning of
the film you probably also heard a very
curious song that's unlike anything
we've done and that's actually Norwegian
joy King a lot of people don't know
which is a folk singing that's done and
so we were just really inspired by that
in a huge way and our technologies team
said well let's let's take from it and
build everything we can we do 3d at the
exact same time we're making the the 2d
version of the movie so it's side by
side and Mike GMO our art director is
very detail-oriented and and I would say
he uses a lot of color thanks Colin he
does like color but what was great was
he actually used the color to evoke the
emotion of the character so it was
grounded in the emotion and a really
amazing color palette I knew that this
story could be big and could could
actually be great as a musical but I
also wanted to do a musical eye the
other movies I've done you know Tarzan I
would say it's a movie with songs it's
not really musical and surfs up had
music behind it but then this was my
chance to do do a real musical where
characters were actually singing so that
was I was personally why I wanted to do
it but I think because of it the epic
scale and everything I think it fits
beautifully there's a lot that you
needed to do and what songs allow you to
do is particularly the way we did it
with a true musical you it carries you
through the plot and emotions it doesn't
stop and then there's a song and then
you keep going there's always some
storytelling that enhances it and there
are things that Bobby and Kristen could
do with a song that as a screenwriter
would take me five or six scenes to
develop we'd have a miniseries if it was
if it weren't a musical I think and so
it was for me it was just being able to
reach emotionally and and an
entertainment entertainment level that
would take a lot more as a writer to do
was it was heaven to work with him and
Bobby and Kristen would always tease her
saying we're gonna take your best scenes
and want to turn those into songs and
those songs will be ours we often talked
about that songs in many ways can touch
the soul a lot faster and a lot more a
lot deeper sometimes than the dialogue
scene can do Adina I don't I don't think
we actually asked her to sing a song the
funny the funny thing there was when we
were asking
Bobby and Kristen what kind of songs do
they think they're gonna write for the
movies so we could tell that whoever was
gonna audition what type of song to
bring in we noticed that almost all the
songs idina menzel had sung at one point
in her life so she sort of rose to the
top pretty quickly what was amazing that
Adina first though is you know she has
one of the most powerful voices but her
speaking voice has a gentleness and a
slight vulnerability and that's exactly
what we needed for Elsa so we didn't
even know it at the time because we were
in the early development we weren't sure
if she was gonna be a full villain or
not and we were trying to push toward
villain and she just was a much more
complex interesting person to work with
and Elsa became much more complex and
interesting and they could to me there
could be no other Elsa it just she
brought everything that was that balance
and then of course we had Kristen Bell
which it was amazing surprise first that
she could sing but she is you know
brilliant wonderfully funny a great
partner and we actually improved a lot
with her because she like me thinks
girls can be funny and so we decided to
really just go for it and have him you
know have a lot of fun with making her
just a real girl and the other guys they
all had musical chops jonathan groff who
Broadway Spring Awakening and lots of
other musicals and amazing talent he
actually we were looking for I was
looking for a voice that was a little
more gruff more Mountain Man esque and a
man a few words kind of character and he
came in and kind of changed it he was so
charming and just this very warm lovely
voice and I finished the audition with
him I was in the room with him reading
off reading the lines and then I came
back into the booth and he had left and
everyone the women and the men were
swooning and so it was it was that was
kind of a slam dunk right of course Josh
then Josh Book of Mormon you know we
knew he could sing quite well and have
fun and then he was one of the first
ones to come in also we loved his voice
and what he created for that we also
have sent Tina Fontana who is now
playing Prince Charming in on Broadway
in Cinderella
again a great great voice and a great
singer and he came in with an audition
he changed the lyrics to I feel pretty -
I am pretty and he's saying it was it
was terrific so we had a lot of fun with
all yeah